talked about lupron bro i don't mean you
want to go into that this is a drug used
to medicinally castrate
uh let's say older people that like to
prey on younger people
this is what they're giving
pre-pubescent boys
to not start the journey and transition
into manhood
my name is michelle forcier
and i have a medical degree from
university of connecticut residency
university of utah pediatrics and i've
worked for a number of different planned
parenthoods for 20 years i do advanced
contraception and abortion as well as
gender hormones and sort of looking at
the whole sort of schema of gender sex
and reproductive
justice so you've done a lot of work in
this field could you just start by
telling us sure
at what age can a child first
begin to
transition into another gender or
identify themselves as
a gender different from how they were
born yeah well i mean there's there's
research and data that show that
babies and infants understand
differences in gender some children
figure out their gender
really early
and the reason why we are say oh that's
that's interesting or important is
because they're figuring out their
gender identity is not necessarily
congruent with their sex assigned at
birth when the doctor sees the penis and
says this is a male
has the sex of male that's a arbitrary
distinction
telling that family based on that little
penis
that your child is absolutely 100
percent male identified no matter what
else occurs in their life
that's not correct
have you ever met a four-year-old
who believes in santa claus so this is
someone who believes that
a fat man is traveling through the sky
and a flying reindeer at lightning speed
coming down his chimney with presence
yeah
would you say that this is someone who
maybe has a tenuous grasp on reality
they have an appropriate four-year-old
handle in reality that's very real for
them agreed agreed but santa claus is
real for them but yeah santa claus is
not actually real yeah well but santa
claus does deliver their christmas
presents
well yeah but he's not real though
to that child they are
when i see a child who you know believes
in santa claus and then let's say this
is a boy and he says i'm a girl
this is someone who can't distinguish
between fantasy and reality so how could
you take that
as a reality
i would say that as a pediatrician and
as a parent
i would say how wonderful my
four-year-old and their imagination is
male gametes that's what makes me male
no your your sperm don't make you male
then what does
it's a constellation in reality
in truth okay whose truth are we talking
about the same truth that says we're
sitting in this room right now you and i
no you're not listening if i if i see a
chicken laying eggs and i say that's a
female chicken laying eggs did i assign
female or am i just observing a physical
reality that's happening in the world
does a chicken have gender identity does
a chicken cry does a chicken commit
suicide let's reframe it because you're
talking you're trying chicken has sex
like any biological organisms an
assigned gender
but a chicken doesn't have a gender
identity so we assign females to
chickens when they lay eggs we assume
they're female if they lay eggs one of
the drugs used is lupron right which
has actually been used to
chemically castrate sex offenders got
him you know what
i'm not sure that we should continue
with this interview because it seems
like it's going in a particular
direction well you're a medical
professional i am a medical professional
so you don't want to talk about
the drugs that you give to kids or
again
i'm a physician and i use medication
you're choosing exploitive words
drugs i give i'm choosing a chemical
word that was in a dictionary that's not
a correct term for puberty blocking i
could like look it up on my phone but
i'm pretty sure if i looked it up you
you can look it up on your phone it says
medical definition the administration of
a drug to bring about a mark reduction
in the body's production of androgens
and especially testosterone and i'm
saying as a pediatrician who takes care
of hundreds of these kids when you use
that terminology you were being
malignant and harmful i mean there are
some who would say that giving
chemical castration drugs to kids is
malignant and harmful it's about the
context of caring for a child and and
seeing the
the suffering that kids can have that
have not been in affirmative home
situations
so we're going on this journey
boys can be girls girls can be boys men
can be women women becoming men
it makes me wonder
what is a woman
what is a woman a woman is someone who
claims that as their identity it could
be many things to many people
it could be many things to many people
guys
take your kids to your doctor when
they're sick this is who they're going
to be speaking to these are the modern
medical practitioners of 2022.
get yourself a muslim doctor please the
love on the legitimacy
yes please
oh my lord
i've seen this before but it's oh my god
it's like my faded memory bias just
doesn't want to remember i know we
watched this last week yeah that's oh my
god okay
okay a lot of things to unpack here i
say we go chronologically the first
thing that she was rambling about is
this whole thing about
kids having a gender identity at a very
young age
okay
oh no bro going to that because
you had a lot to say in our alphabet
episode
just
just think that they don't know
they don't know
i mean they
it's like you said they believe in santa
claus they believe in the easter bunny
they believe in like
spider-man and superman and they they
think this is real
and then she's saying like oh well it's
real to them okay fair enough
but it doesn't change the fact that it's
not actually real
so if the kid now says oh i if a little
boy says oh i'm a girl
that doesn't mean it's real and that
that doesn't mean that a parent should
uh pretty much submit to that
and then the fact that when they start
getting older they don't actually need
the parents consent to take these drugs
i think that's
that's a bit much yeah yeah
is this is this a live word for me i
don't know bro you tell me you told me
this guy
before we got to study medicine real
medicine
um
yeah so this is a biological woman from
what i know she's a doctor
legit doctor
uh shout out to uh
nara or nora thank god i was born in a
third world muslim country
that's the dream
right but
someone has to speak about this being in
the west and
we're not we're not gonna use you know
derogatory language or hate on them or
shaming types so anything like that
we're coming from a strict academic
scientific medical point of view the
same one that these degenerates think
that they're using we're going to use
the same medical terminology and point
of view uh they talked about lupron bro
i don't you want to go into that this is
a drug used to
medicinally castrate
uh let's say older people that like to
prey on younger people
this is what they're giving
pre-pubescent boys
to not start the journey and transition
into manhood actually i mean you're the
uh
the more medical expert here but how
does that make you feel bro just knowing
that like let's say like you have a
younger brother
and he's young and he's like you know
he's going to school he learns about
this whole toxic masculinity you know he
sees manhood as something you know by
the way guys stay tuned for july 1st
inshallah first episode dropping we talk
right about that but manhood has
something taboo something scary you know
he goes on on the media and he sees
either a weak man or he sees a complete
evil vile toxic man he doesn't see a
good model of masculinity so he says you
know what i don't want to become a man i
want to stay a nice boy that i am yeah
let me take this drug and today the
passing bills that parents don't need to
give their consent and it's against the
law for them to do it what if this was
your brother man that's that's hard
that's completely heartbreaking they
talk about a case somewhere in canada
maybe vancouver or something where um
basically this
they've not forced it upon a young girl
but kind of force it on her father uh
and
basically there are legal consequences
for him trying to fight against it
basically which is absolutely absurd
because now we're living in a day and a
time where
uh parents have very little say in what
their kids learn what their kids are
being brought in
you know what fantasy that their kids
are living in spanish but i find this
this trend a lot and it's really
important that we go to the root of the
problem right you're not going to snip
every branch of the tree if you want to
get rid of the tree you go to the root
you dig it out get rid of it right
the root of all this i mean if you look
at it we live in a very liberal society
and and liberalism at its core is do
whatever you know pleases you
mainly physically right whatever pleases
you go for it and they have little care
to what is actually harmful
beneficial or truthful
that's why they allow alcohol that's why
they legalized wheat and a lot of not
just a promoter bro yeah yeah including
they sell cigarettes they legalize weed
in canada alcohol is cool
you know to these people even though
alcohol literally kills
alcohol related murders and deaths sir
you know honestly one of the highest
stats when it comes to death and murders
and so on and so forth and accident
related yes and the dui is obviously all
these crazy things because they don't
care about what's actually healthy and
what they don't talk about allah which
is the harsh truth the harsh reality is
things like trans regret
are there not children out there that
regret the fact that you know they were
ignorant and these doctors put these
pills
down their throat essentially are there
not people like the the the woman that
you saw that looks like a man now
because you only were in surgery because
they were telling her that that's okay
go for it and now she is literally
killing her that we're not going to talk
about the people who uh she talked about
you know do do chickens unalive
themselves people
trans people unalive themselves because
of trans regret because people like you
put it out there it's like no it's
normal it's okay they do it and then
they don't feel normal anymore they
don't because you're not basing it in
truth and she well that's the last thing
i'm going to say
she she said whose truth are we talking
about
my truth is that you're a [__]
that's that is what i'm going to refer
to as for now on because that's my truth
that's a fantasy i live in you're just a
[__] there's only one
truth there's only one reality and i
understand words are a construct so on
and so forth
but when people say gender or sex uh
referring to
biology
it is not subjective it is objective and
yes i understand that there could be
there are different sexes it's not
straight male or female you could have
what is it x
x y or whatever
but if you look at the most rare one i
think it's what is the xxy as a
chromosomal disorder
the most rare one only occurs in males
so even then it's still you're either
male or a female yes there's a maybe a
binary you know in between some places
it does occur other than that there's
no spectrum there is no change and for
you to make it up based on
literally you're just your imagination
and put that onto kids as well man it's
harmful see you can be a legit you know
hermaphrodite you're born with both you
could be a chromosomal hermaphrodite
like you know klein filters or any of
these syndromes where you have like two
x's and one y just like romney was
saying or one y two x's or just one x
that's possible too and you look at
these abnormalities
but they were made perfectly in the
reverence that allah has created them as
such
and i believe that allah has you know
allah doesn't make any mistakes and if
they were created as such khalas
we're not talking about those we're
talking about the people that were born
as xx or xy
and they're letting society dictate that
they should not be that way
omar jose dr mazad miller bless him
talks a little bit about this in his
book he says that you know when these
kids are young right
they have different uh you know amounts
of uh androgens in the placenta right
basically where they're growing in the
womb
and these dictate on a scale and
spectrum according to his predominant
research as a medical practitioner as an
md these dictate where they fall
in a scale of masculinity or femininity
of being a woman or a man subhanallah
take that in
the amount of androgens or hormones in a
mother's womb dictate how masculine or
girly a boy is going to be or how girly
or of a tomboy a girl would be you know
this is what he did and conducted his
research so finally it doesn't mean that
they're a boy or a girl vice versa bro i
can
i can explain this very easily go for a
bro for people right
we
as humans
go through
stages
okay
sometimes
when we're in the stage
we might think a certain way
might feel a certain way right
that passes and once it passes
now we feel and think completely
different yeah
not to air anything out but look at this
this is a tattoo
as muslims we're not supposed to have
tattoos i'm a reaver so i got this
before coming islam now
when i got this tattoo
i was very sure
this is what i wanted
right
why
because that's just the statement that's
your mental state about the mental state
that's right
now as time passed
i literally would look at this tattoo in
the mirror
and i would have this almost like
remorse just forget like what did i just
do
like i can never undo this even if i
were to get the laser removal i could
never fully undo this
and i will go back and forth back and
forth back and forth and i can guarantee
you everyone in this world who has
tattoos
has this well they'll go through stages
where they're actually oh i actually
like what i have and then they look at
it and they're like why did i get this i
made a huge mistake or something like
this or i should cover this up with
something right now what i'm trying to
get at with these tattoos this example
that i'm showing here myself as an
example
is that
i went against
the natural
inclination i went against the fitra
right so that's why there's this huge
regret you do something that's aligned
with the fitra there is no regret
you know what i'm saying so it's like
this whole transition truly for you
yeah yeah this whole transgender thing
and for people who don't know what fitra
is this is your natural inclination it
is your natural internal state the thing
that you are born with yeah
all right so if
again if you do something that's aligned
with that
then you don't feel this regret that's
constantly coming up
um through these stages that things
change but
if you do something that's against
then
let me touch on this point that rule
wrote because you know a lot of people
are wondering why why do food why does
food matter
i was speaking about this with someone
not going to mention any names now but
there are things in our diet there are
things
in the medications that we take the
prescriptions that we take these are all
to some degree greater or lesser going
to be endocrine disruptors today what
does this mean
your hormonal system that allah has
designed perfectly to not need any drugs
subhanallah
to not need any of these enhancements do
not need anything right to modify it
they're it's extremely sensitive bro
right
women take birth control pills that mess
up their hormones for life you know men
take performance enhancing drugs that
change up their hormones for at least a
couple decades we're up to science has
proven this
if not just a few years and cause
permanently damaged in in some way shape
or form in a lot of cases but what we do
know for a fact is when a woman who is
pregnant
is eating you know a lot of the things
today that have
medications or at least chemicals in the
food right gmos
uh pesticides these types of things in
our diet in the water
it really does affect the developing
fetus to some greater or lesser degree
and that's a leading cause of what's
going on with
uh you know these birth abnormalities
and the androgens and the hormones and
it leads to a bunch of these kids
growing up either as masculine girls or
feminine boys and it's one of the
leading causes bro but it's profitable
right so why talk about it big pharma is
one of the biggest culprits between
behind this behind the alphabet movement
behind the sex reassignment thing
extremely disturbing bro
yes
one last thing i want to say to kind of
piggyback off what brother angel said is
um subhanallah there are some things i
would just we shouldn't be allowed to
choose bro we shouldn't be allowed to
choose some things
if allah decides you're going to be a
male or a female
like
you don't have the right to choose you
don't you know i don't you don't you
don't get to choose anything really you
don't get to choose your ethnicity you
don't get to choose your skin color you
don't get to choose what you know class
you're born into if you're a low class
and middle class if you live live in a
first world country third world country
and sex gender whatever you want to call
just one of those things you you just
can't choose and khalas like
if allah gives you something
who's more wise you are allah allah is
more wise
even even even if you for some reason
disagree
you can't actually change it that's i
think that's the worst part about it you
will never actually change it
effectively you can only try your
absolute hardest i think that's why a
lot of people have this trans regret
because a man will look at a woman and
be like i'm going to become that you
will never be that you will only pretend
you are until you get hit in the face
with the reality that you're not and
then it's going to hurt bro and then
you're going to fall into the trans
regret well it's scary read this book
that's harsh
well we got to read it out loud some
people are listening on spotify male 1 i
bless them so sonia writes i'm an ex rad
femme
you guys know what that is and an
anarchist in some sense and i have seen
madness i was close to being an idolist
because of this gender ideology it made
me depressed so i turned to religion
mashallah
may allah bless you
i mean i mean but man
it's crazy bro
these these people who will go through
this what you just said man
like bro they're gonna get to the point
where they do regret it and by that
point it's too late yeah can't go back
like if
if you were a man
from the beginning
and you ended up chopping
yeah
people can say it pp
can can we say this online no no just
say pp bro
pp
just say it bro you're gonna get this so
you're gonna get this whole thing d
platform bro
we're this close guys we are this close
to be completely booted off all social
we've already gotten banned from patreon
and getting
can i say it in spanish no
come on bro come on bro you got a lot of
you got a lot of youtube geeks bro in in
mexico that are that are trying to block
channels left and right they're gonna
see they're already coming for you bro
subhanallah we can't even say the word
guys cucumber they cut their cucumber
off they're cutting the cucumbers and
once they don't have that cucumber no
more and they realize what the
hell did i
do yeah it's too late you can't get that
cucumber put back on i'm sorry
um